there's a wonderful and extremely
romantic idea cited by Steve Jobs the
founder of Apple Computer and it's a
romanticized view of technology and the
idea of human beings being a tool making
animal right we use our technologies as
scaffoldings that allow us to overcome
our boundaries and transcend our
limitations and the idea that Steve Jobs
cited had to do with a study that was
done on the efficiency of locomotion of
all animal species that is how many
calories how much energy did they expend
to get from point A to point B and the
animal at the top of the list that
scored the highest was the Condor right
the Condor was top of the list in terms
of efficiency of locomotion at least I
might have energy to get the farthest
distance human beings were like a third
of the way down the list like just
nothing impressive whatsoever but get
this you give a human-being of bicycle
and it rises to the top of the list
human being with a bicycle immediately
reaches the top of the list of
efficiency of locomotion to get through
point A to point B with the least amount
of energy expended so a tool an
instrument like a bicycle transforms the
capacities of this animal and puts it at
the top of the chain for efficiency of
locomotion and so what Jobs said was he
likened the computer as a bicycle for
the mind the computer has always been a
bicycle of the mind with the Industrial
Revolution we transcended the limits of
our muscles with the digital revolution
would transcend the limits of our minds
terrorism McKenna said the man-made
world is the condensation of human
imagination Kevin Kelley says that
technology is the seventh kingdom of
life he calls
the Technium right living organism with
the same evolutionary forces as
biological evolution our tools have
become scaffoldings of mine and my
friends the sky's the limit in our
capacity to engender our dreams our
tools are psychedelic to my friends the
word psychedelic means to manifest mind
and what is this tool if not the
embodiment and literalization
of mind this has become the condensation
of human imagination iPhone therefore I
am I design therefore I become these
tools and technologies have become non
specific amplifiers of consciousness and
so it is up to the it is up to the
apparatus the cognitive apparatus
employing these tools and technologies
that are extending its capacity that
will determine how we use these tools in
the world and whether we will make this
a better world and engender a utopia
beyond time and create near vana
positively touch a billion people
address the Grand Challenges of humanity
the psychedelic dream of expanding our
minds has been literalized when
psychedelics meet cybernetics we call it
cyber Daleks we live in a cyber Dalek
world
take responsibility let's make our
dreams come true